- Good morning, Believe Nation!
Today's message is Create
Memorable Experiences.
Over to you, Juergen Klopp.
(electronic explosion)
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Entspresso keep me goin'
- [Interviewer] How would you describe
your footballing philosophy?
- Lively.
I think it's, it's not
the smartest way, I know,
- Success is the smartest way.
- Yeah, that's how it is,
successful, it's cool too,
but first of all, having memorable games,
in a row, that's my first target,
that the people really
want to see the next game,
you leave the stadium, you
you can't wait for the next game.
That's what football should be.
And if you can do this very often,
then you will be successful, 100%.
- So I think this is a
message that entrepreneurs
can learn from too.
I think that we want to
create memorable experiences
in our business.
I think you should be
excited about the work
that you're going to do every day.
And yes, you're going to have bad times,
and not everything is going
to be amazing and rosy,
but, at the end of the
day, you should be excited
about the work you're doing.
You should feel like the
work that you are creating
is valuable, is important, is memorable,
that what you did today
is going to matter.
I think that's why a lot of
people become entrepreneurs
is because you want your work to matter,
because you don't want
to work for the man,
you don't want to work at some
job where you're not important,
where you're not havin' an impact.
And so I think, if you
are not in that situation
where you feel like the work
that you are doing is important,
is meaningful, is valuable to yourself and
to the community, to
the people around you,
to you customers, then
that's when you need
to start to change something.
I think a lot of entrepreneurs
who go in to business
just try to make a lot of money,
those are the ones who fail,
because they're not
tryin' to have an impact,
because they're not tryin' to
create something memorable,
because they're not
tryin' to create something
that they can show
their grandkids and say,
"Look at what I did.
"Look at what I created.
"Look at the impact that I had."
That needs to be part of your motivation,
that every day you wake up
and you're doing something
that's going to matter to somebody.
It fuels you.
And I think if you look
at yourself in the mirror
for too many days in a row, and you find
that the work you're doing is meaningless,
is not really havin' a big impact,
then you owe it to
yourself to make a change.
You owe it to yourself,
you owe it to your family,
you owe it to your community, you owe it
to the world, to make a change.
To do something different.
And you apply the same
strategies, same mindset mentality
to everything that you do.
You apply it to your
relationships, you apply it
to your friendships, you
apply it to your life.
You want the time that
you spend on anything
to matter.
And one of the things that I routinely do
is a self-audit, at
least every couple months
I'll do a self-audit, and look at
where am I spending my
time, and does it matter?
And the more that I'm
spending time on things
that don't matter, that
don't matter to me,
that don't matter to other people,
it's not having an impact somewhere,
then I drop those things and
move on to something else.
And you owe it to yourself
to take the greatness that's within you
and create something amazing with it
and stop spending time on
things that do not matter.
If you spent more time on creating
amazing and memorable
experiences, you're going to feel
more fulfilled, you're going
to feel more successful,
you're going to have a lot more money,
and you're going to make
a much greater impact
on the world and the people around you.
So the question of the day today is,
I'm curious, what do you love most
about your business and
what you do every day
that creates memories?
Leave it in the comments below.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally, I want to give a
quick shout-out to Tom Torrez.
Tom, thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book, Your One Word.
It really, really, really,
really means a lot to me.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot
of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every mornin',
♫ Entspresso keep me goin'.
Hey, Believe Nation, as a special bonus,
for those of you
interested in learning more
about creating memorable experiences,
we've lined up a few more
clips that I think will help.
- Well, I said that the
most important thing
is the product, and that really is true,
because you can have all the advertising
in the world, you can have all the hype,
and when people go to the store,
if they try on your pants,
and they don't look good,
and they don't fit, or
they don't like the fabric,
they're not going to buy them.
But, to get them into the
store, to get them there,
you need the other part of the equation.
You need to excite them,
and you need, you know,
pants are pants.
I mean, fashion, you know,
one pair of black pants
and the other pair of
black pants, you know,
so you have to make fashion aspirational.
You have to make people believe
that if they just have those pants,
their whole life is
going to come together,
they're going to get that guy
they want, they're going to get
that new job, they're going to get,
you know, it's because, and that's
just as much a part of the experience,
and it actually, again that
sounds like a terrible,
very calculated thing, but it's not,
because by creating that
image, you have endowed
another quality onto that pair
of pants or pair of shoes,
that really, you know,
makes it something else,
and makes your experience
of wearing that thing
something else, and it enhances your life.
- If it all gives you confidence
to bring out the best in you,
if it gives you the confidence
then it's contributed to your well-being.
- Every hotel I've ever built
has been the highest-grossing
casino in any city
we've ever been, period.
The largest amount of money ever won
by a licensed casino
in the state of Nevada,
when I built it, was Mirage.
That record was broken
when we built Bellagio.
And then, the current record is held
by Wynn Las Vegas.
770 million dollars in
casino revenue last year.
That was more than anybody else
in the history of the state.
170-odd million with slot
machines, 600 million was tables.
Of the 600 million in tables,
52% of it was from Asia.
24% was from Latin America,
24% was from the United States.
Interesting, huh?
450 million out of 600 million was
from outside the United States.
Why are people from San Paolo, Brazil,
Rio de Janiero, Buenos
Aires, Bogota Columbia,
Monterry Mexico, Mexico City,
these are where we have offices,
Hong Kong, Taiwan,
Seoul, Korea,
Tokyo, and all over mainland China,
why do they get on airplanes,
fly over other casinos,
to come to Las Vegas?
Because of the atmosphere,
because of wonderful service,
because of a great hotel staff.
Because it's fun to be
there, whether you gamble
or you don't.
And although we broke
the record at 770 million
for a casino revenue for any licensee
in the history of Nevada,
the not-casino revenue
revenue was 860 million.
Over half, yup.
And it's the 860 that made it possible
for the 770.
I'm goin' through all this with you all
to explain to ya our attitude,
why we do what we do,
and what really matters in our business.
And it's two words, and
everything else is baloney.
Forget all about the
movies, and the Hollywood,
and the "eye in the
sky", and the security.
One thing, one thing matters to the state
of Massachusetts, if it cares
about revenue and jobs, guest experience.
If people have a good time,
if they're well-served,
if they're in an atmosphere
that's exciting and stimulating,
they come back again,
they're willing to pay
more money next year, a little more
than they paid this year,
so that we can cover the
increasing cost of doing business,
unions need increases, people
want to get paid more money,
cost of living goes up,
ya get a franchise because
people have a good experience.
And when you give people
a good experience,
they come from outside the
region into the region.
And if you want to get
people from over there
to come over here, you
better build somethin' here
that's better than there.
- We collect this year
about eight billion dollars
of customers' money.
So thank you, all of you,
for giving us your money.
And what we do is we say,
that money's in trust
to create joy.
We have to turn that into
the most joy possible.
And so we look and we say, for every show,
if a show costs 100 million
dollars, how much joy,
how much viewing did it
create amongst all of you?
If it cost 50 million or
200 million, of course,
you want different amounts of joy, and so
we look at it as how
much joy can we create
of your money, and if we
turn it into joy effectively,
then you're happy and
you tell your friends
and we grow and then we
have more money next year
to turn into more joy.
So we think ourself like alchemists.
We take in money, and out comes joy.
- Add some value.
There's a true societal and
business value proposition.
There's a contribution.
I find, and I don't do this for reasons
other than the fact that
you can't, long term,
build a viable business without
making a real contribution.
Most people look at,
they can start a business,
do an IPO, make some money,
almost always, that leads to businesses
that are round trips.
What I call 'em, because
they go up and go down.
To build a durable business,
you really have to focus
on the value proposition.